[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the video cameras panned and
the still camera is clicked and the
Russian dictator mumbled something to
trump something identified in Russia as
a reference to the reporters in front of
them as quote these are the ones that
insulted you and Trump laughs and Trump
can be heard saying you could be right
about that and Putin and Trump
both laugh Putin in whose country almost
any trace of representative government
is dead and with it an extraordinarily
high number of his opponents are dead
and critics and especially the reporters
who questioned or investigated him are
dead murdered and Trump laughs and back
home
Trump tweets a wrestling video of
himself symbolically beating a figure
labeled CNN and Trump's son tweets a
video of Trump symbolically shooting
down a plane labeled CNN and Trump's son
then confesses to meeting a Russian
lawyer during the campaign in hopes of
getting dirt on Hillary Clinton and our
American reporters determine who created
the hateful dangerous wrestling video
conceal that person's identity announced
they are concealing his identity because
he's promised not to do it again as if
doing it once in a lifetime we're not
bad enough and then everybody sits
around in debates who did and did not
report it fairly Trump laughs at
reporters while seated next to a
dictator and whose country reporters are
regularly murdered back home one
television network with news in its name
goes almost wall-to-wall calling CNN
fake news and some of the other
television networks the ones Trump also
calls fake news the ones Trump suckers
will never watch and have never watched
hire more Trump apologists as
contributors and promote Trump
apologists contributors to Trump
apologist show hosts because they think
they might still get some of those Trump
viewers to watch them Trump viewers the
ones whom Trump is telling to attack
fake news the only question is whether
he means they should attack physically
or merely verbally with all of its phony
unnamed sources and highly slanted and
even fraud
reporting fake news is distorting
democracy in our country this from a man
who reportedly personally approved a
statement written on behalf of his own
son denying that he had met with the
Russians claiming to represent the
Russian government when he had a
statement disproved so quickly that they
had to issue another one the next damn
day the American media continues to
stick to its rules while Trump laughs at
those rules the American media continues
to adhere to some fanciful noble but
stupid conception of balance while Trump
reportedly tells the FBI director he
should consider putting reporters in
prison for publishing classified
information
the American media continues to
broadcast the lies of Trump and the lies
of his spokespeople and the lies of
Trump jr. and Kushner and Flynn and
Manta Ford and Paige and the lies within
lies within lies about none of them ever
meeting with Russians rather than
boycotting these people outright because
the vital distinction has been erased
between facts Trump said it we have to
cover it and truth every word out of the
mouths of these monsters is intended to
put another hole in the First Amendment
the American media continues to give
time to those speakers who can document
and prove the corruption and the
internal threat to our democracy and to
then give equal time to those speakers
who have repeatedly resorted to the most
reprehensible and transparent lives
meanwhile Trump calls the American media
the enemy of the people
a phrase so vile so incendiary that even
the Russian Communist leader Khrushchev
demanded that its use in his post
Stalinist country stop the American
media will not understand will not
acknowledge will not respond to the
simple reality Donald Trump has declared
war on freedom of the press and freedom
of speech in this country fight back one
network with news in its name at
ances first the theory that even if
Trump did collude with the Russians to
alter the election collusion isn't
illegal
and then the same Network makes the
claim that worrying about Trump's mental
capacity is a new low for Democrats the
other networks and nearly every print
news outlet will not consistently and
seriously address whether Trump is
mentally ill won't even talk about it as
much as Fox goddamn News Channel has
because their reporters or journalists
or laymen or because this is a matter
best left for best left for whom when
the democracy is on fire who is supposed
to ring the fire alarm when the emperor
has no clothes and loyalty to this
country and no sanity who is supposed to
say that again and again day after day
until it is clear when the man occupying
the White House calls the media the
enemy of the people
and his spokespersons refuse to let
their remarks at their press briefings
paid for by our tax dollars be recorded
and then go so far as to tell the media
it cannot report that they won't let
them work be recorded what is the
American media's supposed to do record
the news briefings anyway let them throw
you out if that's what they want to try
worse yet
beat them to it and all of you walk out
yes dare them to expel you dare them to
arrest you walk out boycott stop saying
their briefings their rules
stop televising Trump photo ops stop
giving airtime to Trump propaganda and
Trump propagandists chopped' chasing his
viewers and readers who will never
consume your product anyway stop making
sure your coverage is balanced by
countering everybody reporting the truth
with somebody else who is lying
stop pretending this is just a strange
political time stop collaborating with
suppression of freedom of the press war
has been declared against the values of
this country by the man in charge of
this country you are the first target
fight back while you still can remember
this scene put it on your computer
get a tattoo of it Trump and Putin in
whose country journalists are regularly
murdered these are the ones that
insulted you and Trump
laughs fight back President Theodore
Roosevelt said it best to be neutral
between right and wrong is to serve
wrong resist remove peace